- We're monster who help,
and we call ourselves...
- ALL: The Helpsters!
- I hope this works.
- The Helpsters are back.
- ALL: Hooray!
- There's no place like home.
- Ahh...
- Now we can help anyone
with any problem.
- GIRL: Oh, I've got one.
- Oh, and just in time.
How can we help you?
- GIRL: I want to throw a party,
but I don't know how.
- Well, we can help you with that.
Right, everybody?
- We can absolutely help you.
(chuckles)
- So, who's got an idea?
- GIRL: I have an idea.
- Sounds good. Try it.
- GIRL: We're gonna need party snacks.
- I'll go find ingredients.
- GIRL: Oh, and music.
- Cello!
- GIRL: And finally,
I need to invite some friends.
- No, no, that's actually not it.
- We have to get them back
into the right sequence.
- A sequence means
the order in which things happen.
- GIRL: Oh, I see.
First, I have to invite
a bunch of friends
so I know exactly how many
snacks we have to get.
- Helpsters!
- (cheering)
(shudders)
- GIRL: Then, we have to get
enough snacks so everyone can eat.
- Oh, yeah.
- And have some smoothies
while you help.
- I love it!
- GIRL: Finally,
after we've had our snacks,
we need music to start
the dance party.
- Places, everyone.
- A-wick, wicky, wicky, wick,
wicky, wicky, wick.
- Heart.
- (beatboxing)
- A-wick, wicky, wicky, wick,
wicky, wicky, wick.
- GIRL: Perfect.
Thanks, Helpsters.
- I love working with all you Helpsters.
- We did it, everybody!
Yeah, we did.
♪ High-fives and handshakes ♪
♪ What a difference
a plan makes ♪
♪ Had a big tricky problem
at the start of the day ♪
♪ Made a plan and the problem
started melting away ♪
- ALL: Hooray!
♪ No matter how hard ♪
♪ No matter how new ♪
♪ No matter how tangled up
and tough to get through ♪
♪ What a difference
a plan makes ♪
♪ High-fives and handshakes ♪
- Whoo!
♪ A-wooga woo ♪
♪ High-fives and handshakes ♪